[Música]
boa noite
vocês conhecem a fábula do sapo na
panela
eu não sei se isso é um dito popular os
tem algum estudo científico por detrás
confesso que eu também não fui procurar
saber mas dizem que se a gente pegar um
sapo colocar uma panela com água e levar
o fogo
o bicho permanece estático durante todo
o processo de aumento da temperatura no
início ele sente até um calorzinho
gostoso acaba se distraindo e morre
fechado e cozido por outro lado se a
gente pegar um sapo e tentar jogar numa
panela com água
já fernando o bicho dá um salto e sair
de lá no máximo com uma queimadura leve
mais vivo no atual contexto do trabalho
como é que a gente faz pra não virar um
sapo cozido na panela sem perceber
e é nessa ideia que eu quero destacar o
nosso relacionamento com a inteligência
artificial os robôs e automação e como
tudo isso vai impactar no nosso futuro
as mudanças acontecem há tempos mais
recentemente a gente pode citar os
caixas eletrônicos
o sistema de cobrança de estacionamentos
dos shoppings ou mesmo os robôs que
fazem a automação das fábricas de
automóvel
eu penso que nós só os indivíduos no
meio de uma mudança de era de uma
revolução ea gente vai precisar fazer
uso da principal capacidade do ser
humano para poder sobreviver a esse
cenário a capacidade de adaptação
eu busquei dos principais relatórios
recentes sobre o futuro do trabalho para
embasar um raciocínio o primeiro de
newark cor de 2015
um relatório australiano e está muito à
nossa frente em termos de educação e
economia e que focava no impacto da
automação para os próximos 10 a 15 anos
e como isso irá refletir na vida dos
jovens
primeiro o relatório dizia que trabalhos
mais rotineiros são aqueles mais
propensos a automação uma afirmação que
parece óbvio mas assusta no dado
seguinte
na austrália cerca de 40% dos atuais
empregos estão propensos tenham alto
risco de automação nas provas
os 10 a 15 anos sim isso vai impactar a
vida do jovem
primeiro porque esses jovens acabam
iniciando suas carreiras
justamente nessas áreas serão impactadas
pela automação em atividades básicas
rotineiras funções mais simples segundo
porque os atuais cursos de graduação do
país ainda forma os jovens nessas áreas
ensinando as competências tradicionais
que em breve serão desempenhadas pelas
máquinas
aqui é como se fosse aquele sapo que
estava deitado na água quente e só está
esperando pra que ele morra inchado e
com uma falsa sensação de felicidade
o segundo foi o jovem repórter de 2018
do fórum econômico mundial
um relatório mais globalizado nessa
necessariamente focado no jovem e que
tratava do período de 2018 ou 2022
o primeiro dado mostra que até 2022 nada
menos que 54 por cento dos profissionais
dos funcionários de diferentes
organizações vão precisar reorganizar e
renovar as suas competências
segundo o relatório dizia que o declínio
estrutural de certos tipos de emprego ou
seja a eliminação de sete postos de
trabalho vai ser automaticamente
contrabalanceado pela surgimento pelo
crime e pela criação de novos trabalhos
e novas profissões 2018 71% das tarefas
eram realizadas por um homem enquanto
29% por máquinas para 2022
o ponto é 58% de tarefas sendo
desempenhadas pelos homens e 42 pelas
máquinas aqui é aquele sapo que está lá
dentro da panela sentindo que a água
está esquentando e perceber o que é
melhor lá fora antes que a coisa fica
feia demais habilidades que as empresas
mais precisam em 2019
o artigo publicado pelo linkedin em
janeiro desse ano que tratava de quais
habilidades capacidades nós precisamos
para poder sobreviver se adaptar
nesse cenário relatado pelo relatório
que se tem o artigo vai falar das
famosas hearts kills soft skills ajax
kills aquelas competências e habilidades
técnicas que as empresas mais vão
precisar
em 2019 são computação na nuvem
inteligência artificial raciocínio
analítico e o ex design que trata da
experiência do usuário ea gestão de
pessoas como a base principal do
empoderamento do profissional do futuro
já as soft skills ou as habilidades
comportamentais aquela gênero
genuinamente humanas foram criatividade
persuasão colaboração adaptabilidade e
gestão do tempo
sapos que desenvolvem essas habilidades
sequer correm o risco de serem jogados
numa panela com água fervendo
eu penso que quando a gente tem noção do
ambiente que a gente está inserido como
os relatórios citaram ea gente sabe que
tipo de habilidades e competências
a gente precisa desenvolver o que a
gente precisa no final das contas é de
um plano mas não estou falando de um
plano simples de alguma coisa rápida eu
tô falando de alguma coisa que demora a
esteira para mim e pergunta se em por
rodrigo mas como é que eu faço esse
plano é a gente tem que começar de uma
forma simples tentar entender onde é que
a gente tá ea minha sugestão é começar
por três bases de sustentação que vão
permitir esse caminho longo prazo
a primeira delas é saber administrar o
fracasso
toda vez que a gente pensa imagina
qualquer coisa nas nossas vidas
a gente pensa no melhor cenário possível
e aí o pior cenário chega ea gente se
pega totalmente desestruturadas
nós precisamos trabalhar cada vez mais
os nossos níveis de inteligência
emocional para poder sobreviver a isso
segundo paciência assim como essas
esses impactos citados pelos relatórios
podem demorar um pouco mais um pouco
menos para atingir cada um de nós
diretamente nós também precisamos ter
consciência que o nosso processo de
transformação toma tempo mas numa
sociedade que impaciência pressa e
ansiedade impera é extremamente
desafiador
por fim o autodidatismo não dá mais para
depender apenas dos estudos formais
a tecnologia internet deixa a gente
aprender o que a gente quiser a hora que
a gente quiser na palma da nossa mão
na era da inteligência artificial o
nosso conhecimento é o nosso principal
ativo e termos como light on line por
exemplo
ele disse que a nossa vida tem que ser
um aprendizado eterno precisam ser uma
constante uma vez que a gente tem
consciência dessas barras é hora de
partir pra autoconhecimento para que a
gente se realize dentro desse ambiente e
para traçar esse plano um plano
estratégico de longo prazo que vai
demandar da gente é preciso fazer um
exercício
o primeiro é forças e fraquezas forças e
fraquezas e a gente identificar aquilo
que é nosso que é interno que parte de
dentro as forças são os pontos positivos
e as fraquezas os negativos depois olhar
para oportunidades e ameaças
agora eu tô falando de um contexto
externo que está fora da gente
as oportunidades são aquelas coisas que
vão nos ajudar durante essa caminhada e
as ameaças aquelas que vamos atrapalhar
objetivos e metas
não adianta viajar tem que ser uma coisa
plausível não adianta criar o maior
objetivo o objetivo mais difícil
possível para sua vida ou criar aquele
mais fácil e objetivo
pensa naquela coisa maior que se quer
alcançar agora explode isso em pequenos
pedaços pequenos pedaços vão ser as
metas
essas metas precisam ser quantificáveis
e mensuráveis para que você possa
perceber como você está seguindo em
frente
pega tudo isso finalizou bota num pedaço
de papel numa folha de caderno mesmo
cria um plano de ação é como se fosse
uma lista de tarefas e aí você vai
ficando ação ação que você conseguiu
completar por menor que ela seja sabe
como isso vai te ajudar você vai
perceber que o plano está caminhando por
que você vai ver um monte de coisa
arriscada e isso vai dar motivação para
poder seguir em frente
mesmo falando assim é é difícil de
implementar e trazer isso para a prática
e no nosso dia a dia então eu queria
trazer um exemplo é fazer um paralelo
aqui pra que a gente possa tentar
perceber que planejamento estratégico de
longo prazo dá resultado mas eu não vou
trazer um exemplo de carreira o trabalho
aconteceu vou falar de uma coisa que
aconteceu comigo mas na minha vida
pessoal
a corrida de rua ela sempre fez parte da
minha da minha história aqui uma foto da
meia maratona internacional do rio de
janeiro em 2012 e um grande amigo
parceiro de maratonas
só que o final de 2014
eu comecei a sentir muitas dores
na coluna a ponto de não conseguir
baixar para poder pegar minha filha no
colo ela tinha mais ou menos três anos
nessa época no início de 2015 eu tomei
coragem e resolvi o médico o resultado
foi que eu fui condenado a nunca mais
correr na vida e tinha risco de uma
cirurgia é bem grande na coluna
seis meses se passaram em uma atividade
física muita frustração monte quilos a
mais
foi hora de aprender a administrar o meu
fracasso só que não podia aceitar que eu
nunca mais ea correr na vida eu sempre
correr então eu peguei os meus pontos
fortes e fracos
as minhas oportunidades e ameaças tracei
objetivos e metas e colocar isso no
papel para ter um plano de ação que me
levasse de volta a correr
isso foi tempo de trabalhar o
autoconhecimento recomeçar
eu sabia que se eu não podia correr eu
tinha que fazer outra coisa então eu fui
nadar
um ano depois na natação os resultados
já eram bem notórios
eu me sentia muito mais feliz e muito
mais saudável e retomei os treinos ainda
não de corrida mas de caminhada porque
tinha que ser um passo de cada vez
um pouco tempo eu estava conseguindo
completar uma corrida bem leve de 30
minutos na esteira entre começar a dar
algo que eu nunca tinha feito na vida
até voltar a fazer pelo menos 30 minutos
na esteira
foi tempo de trabalhar a minha paciência
eu sabia que se fosse sozinho e ia ser
difícil porque tinha cometido muitos
erros nos treinos e passados
então eu fui atrás de ajuda profissional
além das orientações técnicas deste
profissional
o melhor desta profissional eu percebi
que eu precisava de um apoio emocional
para mim como se eu precisasse de base
de sustentação para equilibrar e voltar
a correr nessas bases não foi difícil
procurar porque ela já tinha o nome
estava do meu lado
karla monteiro isabella monteiro minha
esposa e minha filha respectivamente
depois de passar por um processo uma
dieta bastante restritiva e muita
musculação
estava na hora de voltar a participar de
uma prova por que fazer cinco
quilômetros já não era mais um grande
desafio
e aí eu voltei em grande estilo voltei
nextel ilhabela 2018 uma das provas mais
difíceis do circuito ex-terra eu escolhi
uma prova de oito quilômetros em trilhas
e claro as minhas bases de sustentação
estava lá comigo para me ajudar
nós éramos aproximadamente 300
participantes ea gente esperava muito
sol e da bela na sexta feira à noite
anterior choveu muito choveu o mundo e
no dia da prova tinha bastante nuvem que
fez um pouquinho de chuva mas não foi o
estrago da noite anterior
chuva e trilha não podia ser diferente
muita lama uma hora pouco mais de uma
hora depois eu cruzava a linha de
chegada chorando bastante porque foi uma
prova extremamente difícil onde tive que
ajudar muita gente durante o percurso
só que três anos antes eu tinha sido
condenado a nunca mais queria na vida
só que eu tinha ozu eu não gosto de
parar quem me conhece sabe que eu decidi
que eu vou fazer uma maratona
então os treinos se intensificaram eu
aumentei o volume e eu cheguei aos sete
quilômetros
aos 10 quilômetros aos 15 km de corrida
recentemente rompe a barreira dos 20 km
de corrida
amanhã tenho 24 anos de treino para
fazer foi cumprindo cada uma dessas
pequenas metas dessas pequenas etapas
é desse esse meu objetivo maior que no
dia 23 de junho de 2019 e vou correr 42
quilômetros e 195 metros da maratona do
rio de janeiro
foi com esse tipo de determinação que eu
cheguei até aqui e reinventando e me
readaptando para essa mudança de era
essa revolução que a gente está vivendo
porque eu não aceito comum tem aquela
frase famosa que todos dizem né um giro
que foi sorte mas só eu sei o quanto eu
tive que abrir mão para fazer tudo isso
que eu mostrei pra vocês é administrar
minha carreira e minha vida eu tenho
certeza absoluta que a gente já viu
algumas aqui hoje que cada um de nós tem
as nossas histórias para que a gente
possa administrar do nosso jeito
e por falar em carreira e vida eu quero
deixar a mensagem final pra vocês eu
também faço orientação de carreira para
as pessoas normalmente elas me procuram
para falar da gestão das suas carreiras
e vem falando da sua vida profissional
do seu trabalho do que elas ao mês
o que elas querem das suas promoções dos
seus objetivos
eu para respiro e volta para ela
perguntando quem era mas como é que está
a tua casa tua vida pessoal ser casados
e têm filhos e de um cachorro papagaio
tem que ser cuidada pessoal pra mim fala
assim por rodrigo de culpa mas não tô
aqui pra falar da minha vida pessoal
você sabe da minha vida quero falar da
minha vida de trabalho
a gente não tem essa de vida pessoal ou
vida profissional
é tudo uma coisa só a gente está bem no
trabalho a tendência é que a gente
esteja bem em casa
a gente está bem em casa a tendência é
que a gente esteja bem no trabalho
se uma dessas duas coisas estiver mal a
tendência é que a coisa do outro lado
esteja mal também como indivíduos nós
somos únicos
eu não tenho um botão de liga/desliga
que me diz quando estou na minha vida
pessoal ou quando eu tô na minha vida
profissional
e pra mim é enxergado o todo vida
pessoal profissional e as mudanças estão
ocorrendo no mundo que seremos capazes
de vencer mais uma revolução
obrigado
[Aplausos]